hello and welcome to Playstation grenade
Monster Hunter world is a game I have
high hopes for what could be better than
teaming up with friends to hunt down
hulking beasts and craft their pelts
into armor the gameplay loop of plan
track kill and carve or capture if
that's more your bag has had players
engaged in the first monster hunter back
in 2004
[Music]
thirteen years later and the franchise
have struggled to make an impact in the
Western world even though it has 40
million players worldwide
monster hunter world is here to rectify
that and I'm optimistic that the game
will achieve success in the West capcom
have released footage of all 14 weapon
types in the game and my words they're
some insane armaments and skills on show
the great sword may be the centerpiece
in the advertising campaign because well
just look at it race cause it's
mind-blowing but here are seven other
physics-defying weapons we can't wait to
use in monster hunter world for your
inner caveman why not bring a rock on a
stick okay so it's not built for the
nest but if this prehistoric bludgeoning
tool is your thing then it's hammer time
the highlight seems to be repeatedly
beating a helpless animal round the head
somebody call the RFP dear something
with a little more Flair is the
longsword
this is classed as a light weapon and
allows for fast-paced movement and
repositioning long sword being a samurai
also allows you to perform this attack
it looks like some [ __ ] wave projects
out comes out of Assad but we'll have to
see closer to the time if your combat
style is to inflict damage from afar
then the bowl will let you live out your
Archer fantasies throw one of the
greatest things about the bow is the
ability to cope each arrow to inflict
different damage types of poison
paralyzed or even cause the monster to
fall asleep if you're the Legolas or
Robin Hood of your group this one's
probably for you if you have a yearning
for bullets the heavy Boggan and your
back every bugger utilizing machine-gun
fire mortar attacks and even cypher
light explosive rounds
[Applause]
there are hybrid weapon types available
in most on - well - the gun land
perfectly combines well a gun and the
last jar long but not only that a shield
to your defense is important so whether
you're up close and personal or at the
safe distance the gun lands has you
covered
and look he even shoots a shell which
embeds itself into the head of a great
jagira that for example
this weapon is the charge blade and has
morphing ability switching from a sword
and shield into a hulking great packs
charge blade the sword and shield are
used to store for build energy and then
that is less out through the power of
the axe two weapons in one point the
shield's defense keeps you in the fight
and when the time is right
bring out the axe just don't do it
accidentally
by my last pick I couldn't decide
between the insect glaive and the dual
blades both offer aerial assault and
deal for the member of your team who
want to jump around like a Russian
gymnast after a sugar rush they don't
have many defensive options but who
needs defense when you're running around
jumping and spinning around like a
madman so what takes your funding
there's seven while weapons we didn't
look at but we will cost to the game's
release in early 2018 at this point
Monster Hunter world is looking like the
best in the series and will hopefully
attract more players in the Western
world the combat system is a work of art
the aesthetics unique and engaging - I
for one cannot wait to get my hands on
this one but what about you I would love
to know your thoughts I'm Adam from
Playstation grenade it's been a pleasure
I'll see you next time